آه آها ناسا ، إنها وزيرة
الاستثمار والتعاون الدولي في مصر
أيضًا معنا هنا مثلما نسيت أسناني
وأصبح الجو أكثر برودة ، نعم الله الكلام
هو جون الصم تيريس زميلي من
أبو ظبي بالطبع في
محرر الأسواق الناشئة ، دعني أبدأ مع
وزيرك لأنه  أشعر بإحساس
متجدد بالثقة من الوفد المصري
هنا ، ما هي رسالتك إلى
أولئك المجتمعين هنا في دافوس إلى
بقية العالم هذا الأسبوع حقًا
إنه وفد قوي جدًا قادم
من مصر برئاسة نشوة
رئيس الوزراء د.  مصطفى المتنمر بلدي
، ولدينا بالفعل رسالة واضحة
لنقلها وهي أننا نجحنا للغاية
في تنفيذ
برنامج إصلاح اقتصادي جريء وشامل
بدأنا في جني ثمار
هذه الإصلاحات الإصلاحية ، وبالتالي نحن
هنا لنقل رسالة  أن مصر
قد تم تغيير موقعها لجذب المزيد من
الاستثمارات وأننا على استعداد للقيام
بأعمال تجارية مع جميع أصحاب المصلحة لدينا
سواء من القطاع الخاص أو
شركائنا من
المؤسسات المالية الدولية ، حسنًا ، دعنا
ننتقل إلى سبعة أرقام جون نعم في
الواقع النمو يبحث  قوية لعام 2018-19
في السنة المالية الخاصة بك ، 66 في المائة وهي نسبة
عالية من الاعتماد على النفط والغاز الآن
بسبب الاكتشافات الكبيرة التي حصلت عليها
في البحر الأبيض المتوسط ، كيف يمكنك سحب ال
ستثمار خارج النفط والغاز بس
ب الإصلاحات التي تحصل عل
ها  ها أنت تحصل على الاستثمار الأجنبي المباشر مع
الاستقرار والنمو الأقوى بالتأكيد
لقد تقدمنا إلى الأمام بإصلاح اق
صادي شامل للغاية وم
ثر  برنامج مع ركيزة أساسية
لجذب المزيد من مشاركة القطاع الخاص
في الاقتصاد ، لقد
قمنا بالكثير من الإصلاحات التي أنت
على دراية بها جون والتي أدت إلى تحسين
بيئة الأعمال وأيضًا
تشجيع القطاع الخاص على الدخول
في المجالات الاستراتيجية التي  لم
نشارك في مثل
الطاقة المتجددة ، ليس فقط الغاز والنفط
ولكن أيضًا
قطاع الطاقة المتجددة الأهم ، وهذا شيء نحن
فخورون جدًا به وأنا أنظر إلى حظر
أحد أكبر محطات الطاقة الشمسية في جميع أنحاء العالم
وهذا هو المكان الذي يوجد فيه  هذه
رسالة رائعة للمصريين الدوليين
اللذين يعيشان في المنزل والذين يواجهان
معدلات تضخم على سبيل المثال تزيد
عن خمسين بالمائة ، ما هي الرسالة
محليًا وهل أنت قلق بشأن
النوع المحتمل من التداعيات من
إحصاءات مثل تلك.
الأرقام ومن
المهم جدًا أن يكون
الجليد العالمي FG ركودًا أو تباطؤًا قليلًا
ولكن الأهم هو أن ننظر
في مصر ، ارتفعت حصة
شركة LGI من هذا fgi على مستوى العالم
، وهذا أمر مثير للإعجاب في حد ذاته ،
وأنت محق في نظرنا بعناية في
الآثار المترتبة على برنامج الإصلاح الجريء هذا ،
لذلك يجب أن أعكس أن
المدينة الرئاسية قد وضعت  رؤية كبرى
لمصر ، لكن الحكومة
حرصت على
اتخاذ إجراءات التخفيف ومعالجة أي اختيار سلبي ،
لذا حتى في ظل ضغوط التضخم
، حققت مصر أداءً جيدًا للغاية على هذه الجبهة
وانعكس ذلك في الرقم الذي
يعود إلى وجهة نظرك بشأن الاستثمار الأجنبي المباشر في مصر.  تم
تصنيفها كواحد من أكبر عشرة اقتصادات
في جذب الاستثمار الأجنبي المباشر وفي
تحقيق النمو ،
نحن أيضًا رقم واحد من حيث
القارة الأفريقية ، ولا أعتبره
سياقًا مهمًا للغاية حيث ستكون
مصر مختلفة مع الاتحاد الأفريقي
في غضون أيام قليلة  الوقت
الذي يساورك فيه القلق الآن بشأن الهجمات المتفرقة
التي ما زلنا نراها في السياحة ،
اعلم أن الرئيس يحاول
تأمين تعافي أرقام السياحة في المنطقة ،
لذا حصلت على دفعة في نموك
لهذا السبب ، ولكن كيف تقنع
المستثمرين ، أريد استخدام هذا
كقاعدة لسوق كبير تسعين مليون
مستهلك للقفز إلى إفريقيا
للقدوم إلى أوروبا ولكن لا يمكنك تجاهل
وجود مشكلة أمنية في
البلد في الواقع في  تم تحسين قضية الأمن في
مصر بشكل كبير
ويمكن أن تراه في سياق
جميع الدول المجاورة
وهذا واضح للغاية وفي الواقع هذا
هو تصور المستثمرين
الذين يرون في مصر كوجهة يرون
مصر كبوابة إلى إفريقيا
ولهذا السبب سترى أن الكثير من
الشركات متعددة الجنسيات والشركات الكبرى
تستثمر الآن في مصر إما التوسعات
أو حتى الاستثمارات الخضراء ، لذا فإن
الأمن هو أحد المجالات الرئيسية التي
حققنا فيها الكثير من الإنجازات
والتقدم الذي فزت به.
أتفاجأ عندما أسأل أنه مع هذا
الشعور المتجدد بالتفاؤل والأرقام هي في
الواقع مثيرة للإعجاب ما هي
الفرصة لبيئة متجددة
حيث تنتهك حقوق الإنسان  لا تتصدر
عناوين الصحف في جميع أنحاء العالم في مصر ،
وربما في الواقع قد تتجاوز الأرقام الاقتصادية
ذلك نوعًا ما ، ما يتم
فعله ، هذه هي الإدارة
التي تهتم كثيرًا بالإدارة
وأعتقد أنك هنا
تتضمن تعريفًا واسعًا لذلك.  أشياء كثيرة ،
على سبيل المثال أحد المجالات الرئيسية
هو حق الشباب في
المشاركة بفعالية في
المجال الاجتماعي والسياسي والاقتصادي ،
وحق كل مصري في الوصول إلى
مجموعة واسعة من الخدمات التي يحتاجون إليها
والحق في التحدث و  أعتقد أن هذا
أيضًا تأثير كبير يتمثل
وينعكس في الأرقام ، لذا إذا نظرت
إلى عدد البرلمانيين الشباب
الذين يشاركون بنشاط
ويتحدثون بصوت عالٍ فيما يتعلق بمخاوفهم
من برامج الإصلاح
وتطلعاتهم ، فإن مشاركتهم النشطة
حتى على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
أعتقد  هذا واضح جدًا في مصر ،
لذا فهذه أولوية ولكني أعتقد أنه من
المهم أيضًا أن نكون هنا في World
Economic For  أم أن ننقل
كحكومة رسالتنا الواضحة الخاصة
بالشفافية في الشمول في جميع جوانب
الحياة